Russian investigators say overnight they
have recovered the black boxes from the
jetliner
that made a deadly emergency landing in
Moscow at least 41 people were killed
there when the plane burst into flames
during a very hard landing in Moscow
yesterday the airline Aeroflot says at
least one American was on board but the
US Embassy has yet to confirm that part
of the story Roxana Saberi is following
developments from London and joins us
now with the latest Roxana good morning
good morning Russian investigators say
they're now looking into three possible
causes for the disaster inexperienced
pilots equipment failure and bad weather
some passengers and crew members claim
lightning struck the plane just after
takeoff as the Russian jet touched down
massive flames erupted from the plane
trailed by clouds of smoke for several
moments the plane skidded sideways
finally coming to a stop cell phone
video shows what happened next
passengers escaping on exit slides at
the front of the plane and staggering to
safety some carried luggage fueled this
passenger says flight attendants were
pulling people from the plane as
temperatures around them soared but
dozens didn't make it out and today the
Russian state news agency Tass says most
of them suffocated when the plane filled
with smoke Aeroflot flight 1492 had
taken off from one of Moscow's main
airports early Sunday evening bound for
the northern Russian port city of more
mosque but shortly after takeoff the
airport says the plane circled back for
unspecified technical reasons before
making an emergency landing as
investigators look into what caused the
crash
Russian media are reporting the plane
did not have time to dump its fuel
before hitting the tarmac which former
National Transportation Safety Board
member johngoh Leah says may have
sparked the fire landing gear is tough
but it's not indestructible so they may
have been they may have overloaded it
because the airplane was overloaded and
may have broken the wing and spread all
this fuel out and with thought breaks
and heart engines ignition is it's very
possible Russia's national airline
Aeroflot began flying the Sukhoi ssj100
jet eight years of
this is the second deadly accident
involving the aircraft the last one in
2012 in Indonesia killed all 45 people
on board
John Russian media say authorities do
not plan to ground the aircraft at this
time
all right Roxana Saberi in London Thank
You Roxanne